[Music]
are you ready
this is the main event
the let's get it ready
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
who wants a selfie
tentacular i've got your whole life
story tattooed on my body
yeah
in a long history of monster wrestling
there has never been a champion quite
like kentucky
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
the drive
the discipline to become the next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him did
he eat
thank you that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what
yeah that's going to be a hard no for me
[Music]
oh boy oh this is my nightmare
welcome to stoker the birthplace of
monster wrestling this is incredible but
for this once proud city to survive
a new champion must rise
steve wake up are you pretending to be
asleep right now
listen steve might not look like much
but there is a champion monster inside
of him did he eat one
thank you that felt great
maybe they're right winning's not really
my thing not yet we start training
tomorrow
6 a.m
you're you're serious
let's start over what do you love to do
sleeping really sitting not helping oh
there's also dancing what
i don't like dancing that's so
[Music]
okay yes i love this wrestling is 80
footwork
not bad for 22 tons
are you ready to save this city yeah
execute plan tango
holy guacamole and chips for lunch today
you want to kiss a very questionable
opponent and dancing it's a disgrace to
the sport for a total joke that's how i
felt my whole life but you believed in
me
okay enough with the sappy stuff ah it's
showtime we need to beat the
biggest hammer
the baddest
this is gonna be fun bro
[Music]
and if you live let's get froyo
afterwards oh i love froze wait if i
live
down
[Music]
bye